joining us now author of the upcoming
bestseller the Russia hoax the illicit
scheme to clear Hillary Clinton frame
Donald Trump Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett okay he's writing a book I just
found out tonight this is gonna be a
best-seller - they're gonna be fighting
against each other
the case against impeaching Trump famed
Harvard Law Professor Alan Dershowitz
actually I think the books are
complimentary I would like to do events
with both of you
book signings and I think we could do
like an hour debate and then you guys
signed books and I have a beer it's a
deal very great happy to do it
all right let's let's go - first I got
to ask you about this whole issue with
me professor Dershowitz you didn't know
that I was being sarcastic first of all
you had a perfect constitutional right
to make the comparison I may not agree
with it but you have the right to make
the comparison with Hillary Clinton
that's a constitutionally protected
argument obviously you did it in a sense
of sarcasm saying look at what she did
hey but if you won't get away with it if
you don't do it it is absurd it is
ridiculous to see the media have to take
Best Lawyers that will take me on as a
client right here I think I'm pretty
safe you wouldn't need us I can find you
a first-year student I would win that
these people get on air it's crazy well
I I suspect that the people who were
criticizing you never actually listened
to what it is you were saying I saw this
clip for the first time you just played
a some guy saying a cease and desist
order ought to be had against you if
that guy is a lawyer he's as dumb as a
bucket of hair look the US Supreme Court
said in 1988 so famously that satire and
parody is protected speech sarcasm does
not constitute inciting a crime those
people who are criticizing you for that
have no idea what they're talking about
legally everybody at home you just saw
why these books are gonna be bestsellers
all right
the DOJ there was a spy probably two
maybe more and they you believe you're a
constitutional attorney Congress has a
constitutional role in oversight checks
and balance of separation of powers
why won't they turn the documents over
well they should look I'm a civil
libertarian who goes back to the
anti-war movement when informers were
put in the anti-war movement they were
put in the anti a Martin Luther King
movement the king was spying on her if
aquire horrific way
and so as a civil libertarian when you
put somebody in a campaign I want to
know why I want to see the justification
maybe there is a justification maybe it
was business as usual but the American
public has the right to know everything
about that and make our own judgement we
were heartless civil libertarians
profess this is a scary time listen I am
as pro law enforcement as anybody yep I
love RF my mother was a prison guard my
dad worked in probation I you know it
was a big deal all my family there were
many of them were police and to made the
FBI and that was the top of the hill
look I never pass a policeman in the
street without thank you him I do the
same we do it firemen police love them
schoolteachers you know people who work
hard to give us our status their life I
want them to know I appreciate you every
day than when I do the same all right so
they won't hand it over then you got
Rosen Stein's conflicts and I'm thinking
they promised they would hand it over
great why Congress has every legal and
constitutional right to see these
documents those who are seeking it
actually have security clearance the
gang of eight so there's no valid legal
justification for withholding it and yet
the Department of Justice and the FBI
have a long and distinguished record
over the last year of concealing
evidence redacting records under
national security terms and then when we
find out when they're unsealed there was
no such thing what I would recommend
however is for Congress to immediately
write to the Justice Department and say
do not destroy a single draft we want to
see what the original look like we want
to see every change we want to who
changed it why it was changed and when
it went a Specter general would have it
you would have it you cannot trust a
briefing as trey gowdy seem to say
they're just telling you what they can
get away with the bare minimum you have
to see the documents themselves I've got
a go but your books are so complimentary
and I'm thinking out of the box in the
moment here I would love to do an event
with both of you three good for the
country